R. THIS RULES COMMITTEE OF
THURSDAY MAY SIXTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER- PLEASE BE ADVISED AN
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDINGS
BEING MADE OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDING IS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDED THIS TURN MUST
WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES TO
COMPLY WITH GUIDANCE ON
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. ATTENDEES
MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES. THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING. A
VIOLATION OF THESE RULES MAY
SUBJECT AN INDIVIDUAL REMOVAL
OR OTHER AND FOR SOME PROCESS.
AND AS WE COMMENCE I DO WANT TO
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
TO OUR HAPPY VAN. I'M HONORED
TO HAVE YOU HERE- ON THE RULES
COMMITTEE. MR SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY
HERE CUNNINGHAM SENATE FLOOR
GIPSON YOUR LEE YEAH
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS RAMOS. RUBIO
THE APPROVED WHAT WEBER. THE
FAR WE HAVE A CORE WE HAVEN'T
AGENDA IS OUR MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA MOVERS A GIPSON
SECONDED BY MAYES RUBIO MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
BENNETT. FLORA FLORA GIPSON AYE
GIPSON AYE LEE. AYE LI AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS. RAMOS RAMOS I RUBIO.
RUBIO I. COULD WHAT I. COULD
WELL I WEBER. WEBER HI MOTION
PASSES TO MOTIONS PASSED I
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING ME I
WILL SIT HERE FOR A MINUTE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOUR
VISION AND YOUR AND YOUR.
I
THAT IS ACTIVE AT THE SITE
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS.
THIS
MEETING OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
IS HEREBY ADJOURNED.